[Applause]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh now what have you done that's done
knots
yeah right no that's Dwight D Eisenhower
Oh bang don't worry we'll leave it there
this'll be fine this has been on my desk
for 26 years since ever since that fell
over the show's gone a little sideways
what happened to you are you okay
don't I look good you look amazing I'm
wearing a coat that someone else picked
out because I'm an adult and I can't
pick out my own clothes yeah yeah look
at the people that I work with are like
we should have someone else dress you do
you have that you have a stylist now but
occasionally what someone else pays for
it yeah
so that you didn't pick this out and
then you put it on and then when someone
complements you and says hey you look
really nice that's a nice jacket do you
fess up and say I do because I'm
embarrassed because I'm hopefully I can
pick out my own clothes yeah I mean I do
have someone help me put on the clothes
[Laughter]
my pants how was your holiday did you do
anything fun I'm still recovering I'm
still recovering I've got five kids and
at Christmas I had all these shows in
Florida so at Christmas on Christmas Day
my family and I went to Disney World as
Jesus would have wanted
and I know there's a lot of people that
love Disney and I just want them to know
they're wrong no I've been I've been
multiple times and I you know I realize
Disney is like for me it's like
jalapenos I never learn I can handle it
and then a couple hours later I wish I
was dead
yeah so what happened you took the whole
family and did they have a good time did
you have it did you enjoy it I mean it's
big that's the most crowded day of the
year right yeah it's could they not have
a good time dragging Jim Gaffigan around
complaining but I mean that's the worst
day to go as Chris Layton is it is the
worst day but you know there's you know
I feel sorry for you see grandparents at
Disney World and like what kind of crime
did they commit dragged as senior
citizens right it's like they must have
done something wrong you know tell mom
and dad we're taking you to Disney no I
can't walk we're gonna put you in a
scooter
I can't go on Rogers watch a Stan line
and then you're gonna watch us I'm on a
very strict diet
you're gonna eat fried food and never
pool again I said you did it you did it
you always work blue oh that was my goal